every Pokemon game is set apart by its
location starters and legendaries we got
a glimpse of Sun and moons legendaries
in the last trailer but now we know a
lot more about them I'm Tony and this
game spot news update comes straight
from the Aloha region Pokemon sons
legendary is so Gallio a psychic steel
type lion its signature move is son
steel strike which attacks with the
force of a meteor disregarding the
opponent's abilities speaking of which
so galios ability is called full metal
body which prevents its stats from being
lowered by enemy attacks pokemon moons
legendary is Lou Gnawa a psychic ghost
type bat its signature move is moon
Geist beam a beam of light that also
ignores the opponent's abilities and as
for lune alisone ability shadow shield
means you take less damage from an
attack whenever you're at full HP the
new Pokemon trailer also showed off sun
and moon supporting cast plus the new
Rotom infused pokedex will get our hands
on all of this new content when Sun and
Moon releases on November eighteenth for
now you can hang around GameSpot for all
the latest in the world of Pokemon
Oh